foreign
starts off this hour in Jacksonville
Florida hi Kim Welcome to the Ramsey
Show
hi thanks
thanks Michael how are you better than I
deserve how can we help
um well to the point of the question
um is there ever an exception
to start investing before you're out of
debt why
um so I'm an RN I've always worked W-2
jobs last year I started as a 1099
formed an LLC and I'm filing as f-corp
and my CPA is telling me that I need to
invest for retirement because I'm not
contributing to Social Security and for
the tax deduction
but we have my husband and I have about
24 000 in debt right now
um your your CPA does not need to be
giving you advice on this because he's
not very smart
um the
you are paying uh Social Security it's
called self-employment tax
it's 15.3 percent
okay you don't get out of Social
Security uh unless you are a pastor who
opted out uh for as a conscientious
objector but you don't have that option
and I don't either so we get to pay that
uh when you're self-employed you pay
both sides of Social Security uh that's
because the government loves small
business and they want to double dip on
you and so you get to pay 15.3 so you're
doing that uh so your CPA is wrong uh
then secondly you guys are young clean
up your freaking debt so you have some
money to invest yes
um so we started listening to your show
a few weeks ago and I just got your
Total Money Makeover books so well we're
working on it is he kind of trying to
scare you into thinking that you're
running out of time because you haven't
started investing yet
well and that's not entirely true um
when I had my W-2 jobs and I worked in
hospitals I do have a 403b and a 401k
okay yeah and how I mean look I I tell
folks this all the time with my husband
and I it took us seven years to get out
of all of our debt and we didn't invest
during that time
We Didn't Start investing until our
mid-30s and do you know what we are
perfectly fine
yeah we're fine you've got you've got
the time because here's the thing once
that debt's cleaned up you're gonna have
more money than ever to invest anyway
and you're gonna make up the difference
here's the other possibility he may be
wanting you to invest to save on your
taxes
to create a a pre-tax investment which
is not the best way for you to investing
right now you need to be doing Roth
which is an after-tax investment gives
you zero tax benefit today but it grows
100 tax-free and so never do a a pre-tax
investment to save on taxes today
because 96 percent of what will be in
your account at your age when you get to
65 will be growth four percent will be
what you put in and took a tax deduction
on and it's a hundred percent taxable if
you do it his way and uh ninety six
percent of it has no taxes on it and
four percent already had the taxes paid
on it if you do it my way with the Roth
so again your CPA needs to stick to
taxes and not Financial advice because
he's not very good at it
there we go
aggravates me so here's the thing let's
go back for a second because it's worth
talking about
um to say
many years ago way back when the
dinosaurs roamed the Earth in the 1980s
the tax law changed and uh to stimulate
the economy they put in unbelievable tax
advantages on real estate then they took
them away
when they took them away a whole bunch
of people went broke because they bought
the real estate for tax reasons only not
for good math reasons otherwise the only
reason they did the real estate deals
was for tax they were bad real estate
deals
except for the tax and that's what this
is this is a bad investment deal that
he's suggesting except for the tax if
he's suggesting or she's suggesting a
traditional IRA or traditional 401K
versus a Roth for some young person like
this that's mathematically bullcrap yeah
we would always say to do a match first
right Dave match beats Roth beats
traditional
exactly if you're a married couple it
doesn't matter whose 401K we're doing it
with we take all the match we can get
first because a match is a hundred
percent rate of return free money you
can't mess this up
if your mutual fund makes a 10 or 11
return that's great when your boss puts
in a hundred percent that's a match
that's a hundred percent rate of return
you really can't screw that up okay and
here's the thing 82 percent of the
companies that offer a 401k offer some
form of match now so always take
advantage full advantage of the match
when you get to baby step four only when
you get to baby step four and when you
get to baby step four you won't have any
payments so you'll have money to put 15
of your household income into that
that's right then from there we do the
Roth and we do the Roth because it's tax
free that's right so when you go to pull
the money out in retirement you're not
paying taxes on it yeah so if you save
up a million two million dollars it's
going to be a hundred percent zero tax
when you're taking it out that's right
what you've put in was already taxed and
the growth is a hundred percent tax free
and with the new secure act there is no
required minimum distribution on roths
when you turn to 73. oh I love that you
have to record your required minimum
distribute Solutions on your retirement
if you turn 73 and you have traditional
you have to begin taking it out because
they want their freaking tax money
that's why they do that